that's why that's why a lot of men are
afraid of getting married is because
like it's
the cost is so great if you get divorced
like that's 20 of your income that's a
lot
so
but on the other hand you have like
legal protections as a girl
so it's like the the power shifts i'm
not saying it's right i'm just saying
that's how it is
i just i just think it's all about the
examples that you have of a marriage
because
whenever i hear young people talk about
marriage it always sounds so down you
know i can't have enough fun
you know i can't you know go give up
everything can sometime in the future
kind of like oh yeah i will one day and
there's nothing wrong with being
submissive everybody all the women see
submissive a bad thing it's not a good
thing if you've got a man leading you
you know a marriage for a woman
is great she's got nothing to lose she
can go in with nothing and she can come
up with everything so as far as i'm
concerned is this like
if you've got a good example of marriage
then you will see marriage is a good
thing
and all around yeah
good examples of marriages
you know because my mom and dad were
married i got my mom and dad look great
i had some old people that were married
they were great i remember i saw this
woman and she was like well spoken
and she was married to this man who had
money and they've been together for
years and she said i said how do you do
it she said compromise
she goes look at him look at him and she
was all well to do and he was there at
the bar drinking she goes you know and
she'd actually helped him put his money
away to retire and marriage is a great
thing i think sometimes it's the
examples that people see around them
that tarnishes it to make it sound like
you're gonna lose everything because
there's people out there with marriages
that travel together have fun together
it's not about i'm going to get married
to have children it's i'm going to get
married to be committed to this person
then we grow together and children will
come do you think just quickly that
the options
that young people have now
has made that more difficult
too many too many options
because there was a time where
you know it's in your local area you
know the
you go to church or wherever you go and
someone knows somebody and now it's
worldwide well i think i think the
development of birth control changed the
game
because there used to be consequences so
if you slept around like you likely
would get pregnant
where then you could just sleep with
whoever you wanted
and so if you look at it's really
interesting if you look at
graphs of when the divorce rate started
to go up in the western world it's it's
like the same as when birth can like the
number of women on birth control rollo
tomasi tweeted it if you want to go to
his twitter it's actually really
interesting
because men can't get pregnant yeah well
and then that gives that that's that's
why women um push off marriage later and
later gives them more time to lock down
like the high value guy and and that's
the other thing is like girls think
they're hotter than they are in 2022
because a girl that's a four five six or
seven can sleep with a guy that's an
eight nine or ten but he would never be
seen in public with her he's just he's
just sleeping with her
yeah and so that's what i'm saying like
because girls will think their level is
the guy that they're sleeping with but
it's not it's the guy that you can get
to commit to you so that then you have
girls that are
shooting down the guys that are actually
on their level
and so it leads this that's why it's 50
of women over 30 are single and
childless
then they try to go back to the guys
that were on their level yeah that and
then you men don't want them yeah yeah
because that's why they're left behind
they're with someone of on their level
yeah yeah and i'm curious because um
you're a bit older so
what like what
i'm just curious what are you you're
familiar with red pill it seems like
do you see that that older women get
past
how do i put it
they the guys they rejected earlier will
turn them down later yes
it happens a lot
it happens
because you see the women and they think
oh no i remember there was a man and
he was um
he didn't look younger i didn't look all
that nobody was after him he became a
dustbin man you know nobody was after
him and they got older and he got more
handsome and then he got a nice car and
everything everybody's after him you
know why because they realized how much
dust men wanted how much they earned
and then when they were after him he
didn't want them he got some girl you
know he was a dust man i think he
married like a lawyer or something like
that because she saw his worth and it
wasn't how much he earned he was a good
guy with potential but nobody wanted
nobody wanted him at the time but now
all those women now that you know three
children four children
why is man gonna want to take on you
with two three four children you know
over 35 why
and what mistakes do you see did you see
younger girls make
when it comes to dating and what
mistakes maybe did you make and you
learned from
i got pregnant on the pill
oh wow so yeah first time pregnant on
the pill i was on the pill and you never
missed the day
i was only on it for about a month
okay yeah so and
i got one child you know because i
learnt my lesson but nowadays it's like
it's too easy to go and get rid of a
child
it's too easy to go
and say well then i'm gonna get birth
control and i'm gonna sleep with
everyone because i'm gonna i'm not gonna
get pregnant it's not gonna bother me
but every what the young people don't
realize every time they sleep with a man
you're giving away a bit of yourself
so by the time you've reached 35 there's
hardly anything left to you because
you've given it away to all these people
and they don't realize that men can
sleep with
women i don't mean nothing to them but
women sleep with men and it's emotional
and every time you sleep with a man
you give away a bit of yourself and
that's what the young people don't
realize that they're just giving
themselves away bit by bit by bit
do you think women have gotten better or
worse over time worse why because they
just think they're all that
they're independent
they've got their own money they can do
what they like
they don't need men and then when they
need the men the men don't want them but
they do need men they just don't realize
it yeah
why does a woman need a man that's what
i mean they just don't realize it yet
because you try surviving on your own
without a man
you cannot wake up in the morning and go
through your whole day without having to
rely on a man for something like what
like everything around them wherever you
go you get your petrol wherever you go
and you get the bus whether you the the
the clothes that you wear in the shop
the designer you cannot get through life
without a man
men built the world like they they do
all of the hard jobs in society
everything that makes the infrastructure
run
i'm not saying we don't need men that's
not my view at all but i just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over i feel like the things you're
saying
and the over reliance on men that's what
perpetuates that view because it makes
it seem like a woman literally can't
survive without a man and i feel like
you're linking that like one thing you
mentioned earlier you said that there's
a link between divorce rates and um
when women were able to get access to
birth control and i feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and
she's going to take some of the man's
income in that sense i feel like
um
i've lost my point now i forgot what i
said to typically a lot of i feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think is feeling like how
can you what do you think is feeling no
because you say i feel like i feel like
i feel like so i was just wondering if
you're saying that i do want me to say
no no i don't know i'm is it all feeling
if you tell me you're feeling then
i don't think it's feeling this is what
i mean i feel like women have
what do you want me to say
let's just have something like a tough
girl's time yeah
okay
so um yeah from what you said about
divorce rates and birth control i feel
like that's where women have gained